during the earth's early days a
gargantuan collision left our planet
spinning at an angle
that slight incline allowed life as you
know it to flourish
but what if this impact caused earth to
rotate at a much more dramatic slant
like say on its side
what would our world look like
why is alaska better prepared for this
sideways world
and why would human life no longer be
possible on this blue rock
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the earth was spinning on its
side
around four and a half billion years ago
during earth's infancy our world got
slammed by thea a mars-sized
proto-planet
this collision was so violent that earth
almost turned into a cloud of vaporized
rock
the impact also tilted the earth's axis
70 degrees from its orbital axis
lucky for us and all the life that came
after the enormous crash
this extreme tilt decreased over time
and settled at 23 and a half degrees
and this is the planet you live on at
this very moment
but what if the encounter with thea had
flipped earth 90 degrees
how would that earth have differed from
our own
hey if you want to flip your world on
its side you need to check out one dream
one dream is the premier entertainment
and educational video service with over
6 000 hours of video courses
documentaries and series the folks who
brought you the great courses are back
with even more bold and mind-blowing
experiences that will ignite your
passion for learning no matter what
you're interested in or where your mind
wanders one dream has you covered hey
our planet is in crisis right now so get
informed on humanity's next steps with
the documentary series solving for xero
the search for climate innovation the
experts in this dock opened my eyes to
the ways concrete and steel production
contribute to climate change and the
alternative methods we can use to fight
this crisis
feed your brain at onedrive.com
what if show click the link in the
description below to start your free
trial today explore a whole new world of
knowledge today before everything gets
flipped over
so what's the deal with this tilt anyway
well it gives us seasons
as earth orbits the sun our hemispheres
take turns facing our star
when the northern axis is pointing
toward the sun the northern hemisphere
receives more sunlight and experiences
summer
meanwhile the southern axis receives
less sunlight so the southern hemisphere
can have its winter
six months later it all shifts and it's
now the northern hemisphere that
experiences winter while the southern
hemisphere enjoys the summer
all because of our planet's 23 and a
half degree tilt
now that's what i call fair and balanced
but balanced is not a word that would
describe the earth if it had an actual
tilt of 90 degrees
if our planet was spinning on its side
the north pole would face the sun
head-on well the south pole would be
completely hidden away from it
after six months this would change now
the south pole would face the sun while
the north pole would be thrown into
darkness
then what would all this mean for you
well dealing with a six month long
winter and a six month long summer
that's what
it might not sound all that bad but
let me assure you your days would be
radically different
whenever one of the hemispheres was
directly facing the sun it would get
sunlight
24 7 for six months straight
the united states sweden japan and all
other countries in the northern
hemisphere of the planet would be
blasted by constant sunlight for half of
the year
and i mean it would be a constant summer
day
you'd have to get used to sleeping while
the sun is up and stockpile your
sunscreen
that might sound familiar to residents
of barrow alaska who already experienced
sunlight for 84 straight days
this is because when the north pole is
angled toward the sun all the areas
within the arctic circle are unable to
fully escape its rays
this phenomenon is known as the midnight
sun
during july the northern hemisphere
could experience scorching 80 to 100
degree temperatures that's hot enough to
boil water
the blazing climate would be
particularly ferocious at the poles
especially in the north
the rising ocean temperatures would
trigger stronger and more frequent
hurricanes and because the weather would
now be all over the place the entire
planet would experience severe droughts
during the summer months
and that's just half the tail
now let's take a look at what happens
when one of the hemispheres is pointing
away from the sun
yeah instead of a reliable spf
you would need to invest in a good set
of headlights because these six months
would be shrouded in darkness
half of your year would be a long long
night
and on top of those headlights get your
hands on the best winter jacket you can
find
the hemispheres months long night would
be a freezing one
it would become as cold as the north
pole is during its winter with swirls of
frigid winds
you'd see blizzards where florida and
kenya are located today the magic
kingdom would look more like castle
black
the good news is that the earth wouldn't
turn into an ice rock
even during the coldest months it
wouldn't be entirely covered with ice
that's because the poles wouldn't
experience winter long enough to be
completely frozen
you'd see some seasonal snow stretching
from northern africa all the way to the
middle east
only two places might be able to hold on
to that snow throughout the year
the andes mountains of western south
america
and the extreme highlands of eastern
africa
your best chance at ice fishing could be
over the equatorial ocean which might be
the only body of water covered in ice
so
what would life be like on this very
tilted planet
well for starters a lot of our coastal
cities
would now be underwater
that's because on this sideways spinning
earth
all the ice covering antarctica
greenland and mountain glaciers would
melt and this would cause the oceans to
rise 70 meters
many people would be forced to leave
their homes but the problems wouldn't
stop there
such extreme temperature variations
would make most parts of europe
uninhabitable
if you still wanted to stay there you'd
have to deal with punishing winters
followed by boiling hot summers
on the other hand antarctica would hold
a relatively stable climate of around 0
to 20 degrees
talk about a swap
now when it comes to growing food we'd
be working under a tight timeline
you'd only have three milder summer
months to plant and harvest crops
and those months wouldn't go
uninterrupted
the peak of the summer would get so hot
that it would burn fields
you'd only have two one and a half month
periods in the entire year to farm
enough food for billions of people
the resulting mass starvation would make
it difficult for
any civilization to sustain itself
and if you think the unstoppable famine
and flooding of habitable land would be
awful
wait till you hear about what those
summer temperatures would do to you
remember how july could bring about
temperatures hot enough to brew coffee
well hate to break it to you but the
average human will suffer hyperthermia
in 60 degree heat
your body wouldn't just suffer from the
worst heat stroke imaginable
after just 10 minutes it would literally
boil from the inside out
starvation plus flooded cities plus a
world that jumps from frozen to boiling
equals checkmate humanity
as you can see when it comes to
planetary balance
it's all in the details
you can thank our slight 23 and a half
degree slant for keeping the current
weather more or less in check
otherwise we'd need to seriously put our
minds together and come up with ways to
control the climate
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]